[موسيقى]
مساء الخير تمرد فاجنر هو حديث العالم كله
تطور خطير بدا بشكل مفاجئ مساء الجمعه 23
يونيو وانتهى بشكل سريع مساء اليوم التالي
اليكم ما نعرفه حتى الان نبدا بموجزات
سريع لاهم الاحداث الدراميه التي حدثت في
ال 24 ساعه الماضيه قبل ان نتحدث عن جذور
المشكله وتداعياتها المحتمله يوم 23 يونيو
اعلن قائد فاجنر يفكيني
تمرده واحتلت قواته مدينه رستوف الروسيه
الحدوديه داعيا الروس للانضمام له لوضع
نهايه للفوضى والفساد الذي يقف وراءهما
قاده الجيش الروسي وعلى راسهم وزير الدفاع
الذي اتهمه
بانه هو ومساعدوه قد ورطوا روسيا في حرب
اوكرانيا بلا داعم وفشلوا في ادارتها
وانهم ضللوا بوتين وضللوا الشعب الروسي
سبب المباشر لثوره وتمرد بروجيجن هو
اتهامه للجيش الروسي انه استهدف قوات
فاجنر بضربات جويه ادت لمقتل عدد كبير
منهم غدرا كما يقول ما دعاه للتعهد
بالانتقام من قاده الجيش وبدات تنفيذ
تهديداته باحتلال مدينه رستوف الحدوديه
اللي بتمثل معبرا رئيسيا لامداد القوات
الروسيه المشاركه في الحرب بالمعدات
والمؤن الجيش نفى ان يكون قد استهدف قوات
تصاعدت الازمه اخيرا خرج بوتين عن صمته ظل
بوتين صامتا على تجاوزات رئيس فيجنر لشهور
اخيرا خرج بوتين عن صمته
واعتبر ان ما حدث من قائد فاجنر خيانه
وطعنه في الظهر متواعدا بسحق التمرد
وواعدا الروس بضبط الامور رد بروجيجين بان
تصريحات بوتين لم تنصفه ونسب اليه انه قال
الان انتهت الامور ليبحث الروس لهم عن
رئيس جديد مهددا اذا لم ياتي شاي جو اللي
هو وزير الدفاع وقادت جيشه اليه فسوف يذهب
هو لحسابهم في موسكو وبالفعل بدا الزحف
نحو العاصمه الروسيه بخمس الاف جندي
بمعداتهم الثقيله وبشكل يدعو للدهشه وصل
الى مسافه حوالي 200 كيلو مترا قبل
العاصمه الروسيه يعني قطع حوالي 800 كيلو
في العمق الروسي دون ان يوقفه احد وتتابعت
الاحداث ومعها تقديرات من عواصم غربيه
مختلفه ان الوضع خطير في روسيا التي
هذه التطورات خطيره ولكنها لم تكن مفاجاه
تماما للمتابعين لانه قائد فاجنر بروجن
بدا منذ فبراير الماضي اي منذ عده شهور
انتقاداته العلنيه للقيادات العسكريه
وقيادات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه كان تركيزه في البدايه على مطالبه
وزاره الدفاع بامداده باحتياجاته من
الذخيره واتهامه لهم بانهم يقصرون في
ارسال ما يحتاجه من ذخيره لاتمام مهمته في
السيطره على ضخمه
ثم تصاعدت انتقاداته للقيادات العسكريه
واتهمها بعدم الكفاءه والفساد وطوال الوقت
كان بيقارن يعني مثالب القيادات العسكريه
الموجوده في وزاره الدفاع بكفاءه وطنيه
قوات فاجنر التي تدافع عن مصالح روسيا في
الداخل والخارج فين الخارج زي يعني دورهم
في اوكرانيا وسوريا وغيرهما
لكن بدايه من مايو الماضي تزايدت حده
انتقادات
العلنيه واخذت منحنى اكثر خطوره وكان حديث
الصحفي اللي اجراه على قناته تيليجرام في
24 مايو الماضي نقطه تحول ليه نقطه التحول
لان في هذا الحوار لم يكتفي فقط بالهجوم
على وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان كالعاده
والمطالبه باقالتهما
وتحميلهما مشكله كل الخسائر والانتكاسات
العسكريه التي عاناها الجيش الروسي في
اوكرانيا ولكنه وهذا هو الجديد والملفت
انتقل الى انتقاد النخب الروسيه كلها وقال
ان ابناء النخب يستمتعون بانفسهم على
الشواطئ بينما يموت ابناء العائلات
الروسيه العاديه وحذر اذا لم تنتهي عمليه
هذه بين اغنياء المجتمع الذين لا يذهبون
الى الحرب وبين فقرائه الذين يموتون على
ساحات المعارك سوف سوف ينتهي او امره
بثوره كما حدث في عام 1917 عندما تمرد
الجنود ثم ثار ذبوهم وعائلاتهم على النخب
الحاكمه ووجه نصيحه قاسيه لهؤلاء الاثرياء
والنافذين الروس قائلا لهم انتم يا ابناء
العاهرات ارسلوا ابنائكم للحرب وعندما
تذهبون الى جنازاتهم سوف يقول الناس الان
كل شيء عادل وسوف ننتصر في حربنا طبعا هو
بيشير الى
تجربه روسيا الامبراطوريه الروسيه في
الحرب العالميه الاولى لما اندلعت هذه
الحرب في 1914 كان اداء الجيش الروسي جيد
جدا ثم سرعان ما عانى الجنود من سوء
التنظيم ومن خسائر هائله ومن نقص كبير جدا
في الاسلحه والمعدات ادت الى تمرد الجنود
وتمرد الجنود ادى الى تمرد عائلاتهم وكان
ذلك احد اهم المحطات التي قادت الى ثوره
روسيا عام 1917 على العموم نعود الى حواره
اخطر ما في هذا الحوار اللي اجراه يوم 24
مايو لم يكن الهجوم على القاده العسكريين
ولا على النخب الروسيه ولكن الهجوم على
الحرب نفسها والتشكيك في جدوها وقال
باختصار كده انه كل الاهداف التي
خذنا من اجلها هذه الحرب لم نحقق منها
شيئا
وقال ان الهدف الاولاني كان القضاء على
النازيه والنازيين في اشاره للقوى القوميه
المعاديه لروسيا في اوكرانيا لكننا ده هو
اللي بيقول جعلنا اوكرانيا الان دوله
مشهوره في جميع انحاء العالم هم الان مثل
الاغريق او الرومان في العصور القديمه
يعني منحناهم مجدا لا يستحقوه وبالنسبه
للهدف الثاني وهو نزع سلاح الاوكران حدث
العكس اذا كان لدى الاوكران بدايه في
بدايه الحرب او قبل بدايه الحرب 500 دبابه
اصبح لديهم الان 5000 واذا كان لديهم قبل
الحرب 20 الف جندي مدرب بشكل جيد الان
اصبح لديهم 400 الف مقاتل مدرب بشكل جيد
وبالتالي نحن من قمنا
دي الحقيقه بتسليح وعسكره اوكرانيا ولا
ادري كيف بحق الجحيم ده هو اللي بيقول كان
هذا تطور خطير جدا
وتجاوزا واضح لخط احمر ورغم ان انتقاد
جدول حرب يطالب بوتين بشكل ضمني لكنه كان
حريصا الا يمسه بشكل مباشر وركز على ان
بوتين والشعب ضحيتان لتضليل وعدم كفاءه
القاده العسكريين وكان حريص انه يقول ان
عقيدته العسكريه هي احب وطني اطيع بوتين
لا اهتم به اللي هو وزير الدفاع وسوف
استمر في الحرب في اوكرانيا من اجل روسيا
تصريحاته يوم الجمعه الماضيه كان استمرار
لهذا التحول اللي بداوا يوم 24 مايو لانه
عاد ليشكك في جدول الحرب ويشكك في الروايه
الروسيه كلها اللي بتقوم على انهم خاضوا
هذه الحرب للدفاع عن انف من عدوان يضمره
لهم حلف شمال الاطلسي الذي استخدم
اوكرانيا كاداه للعدوان على الروس وقال
هذه روايه جميله ولكنها غير صحيحه لم يكن
هناك اي شيء غير طبيعي على الحدود
الاوكرانيه يستدعي ان نخوض حربا ضدهم وان
القصه كلها يعني فبركها او افتعلها قاده
الجيش الروسي وعلى راسهم وزير الدفاع
لاغراضهم الشخصيه وقال ان وزير الدفاع خاض
هذه الحرب حتى يحصل على رتبه مارشال وعلى
قلاده بطل روسيا قلاده بطل روسيا للمره
الثانيه من خلال شن عمليه اعتقد انها سوف
تكون
حربا سريعه يستطيع ان يكسبها وعاد ليؤكد
في هذا الحوار طبعا انه قصف من جانب قوات
الجيش
قاده الجيش الفسده الخونه اللي بدل ما
يكرمه قوات فيجنر على بطولاتهم ارادوا
تصفيتهم وتتابعت الاحداث كما اشرت
لحضراتكم من المهم جدا وحتى تستقيم الامور
قبل ما نتكلم عن تداعيات ما جرى ان اذكركم
بما هي فاجنر ومن هو الذي يتحدث عنه
الجميع طبعا شركه امن خاصه او جيش خاص
تاريخ تاسيسها من قبل المخابرات العسكريه
الروسيه ليس واضحا بدق ولكن المؤكد ان اول
مره تذكر فيه في وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
كان في عام 2015 لما اشارت وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه الى دور هذه الجماعه الفعال في
حرب اوكرانيا الاولى اللي بدات في 2014
درهم في دم شبه جزيره القرم او في الحرب
اللي دارت بين شرق اوكرانيا والانفصاليين
الاوكران
والجيش الاوكراني ثم بدا اسمها يذيع او
ينتشر يعني من خلال مشاركتها الفعاله في
الحرب السوريه بدايه من 2015 والصراع
الليبي وفي كثير من اماكن الصراع في
افريقيا مثل جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ومالي
والسودان الى
استخدام الروس لميليشيات المكونه من
مرتزقه محترفون وبعضهم من مجرمين مدانين
في السجون ليس جديدا على روسيا ولا قاصرا
على الروس فعلها السوفيتو قبل ذلك وفعلها
غيرهم وطبعا واحده من اشهر هذه الجيوش
قوات بلاك ووتر او جيش بلاك ووتر اللي
استعانت به الولايات المتحده على سبيل
المثال في كثير من ساحات القتال الى
جانبهم وكان واحده من اهم هذه الساحات
التي شاركوا فيها هي العراق افعال مشينه
فيها لماذا تستعين جيوش قويه بمليشيات
ماجوره لمجموعه من الاسباب باتت معروفه
جدا وهي موجوده من زمان اولها ان يقوم جيش
هذه الدوله بمهمه لا يرغب في ان تنسب اليه
فعلها الاتحاد السوفيتي اثناء مشاركته في
الحرب الاهليه الاسبانيه ولكن دي قصه يطول
شرحها وفعلها الروس بما ان احنا بنتكلم
على مؤخرا في اوكرانيا لما تدخل بشكل فعال
لدم شبه جزيره القرد ولما تدخل في الحرب
اللي استمرت لسنوات من 2014 بين الروس او
بين الاوكرانيين من اصل روسي في شرق
اوكرانيا وبين الدوله الاوكرانيه
وشاركت هذه الجماعه للدفاع عن مصالح روسيا
ولكن بشكل غير رسمي يعني الموقف الرسمي
الروسي بيقول ايه ان في
اوكران من اصل روسيا موجودين في شرق
اوكرانيا يرغبون في الانفصال انضم اليهم
متطوعون افتحوا قوسين الجماعات المسلحه
المدربه مثل فاجنر وغيرها للدفاع عن بري
جلدتهم امام اضطهاد الدوله الاوكرانيه
للمواطنين الاوكران من اصل روسيا اما انا
كجيش روسي فلم اتدخل ابدا وانا مستعد ان
العب دور الوساطه بين الوساطه بين مين بين
الحكومه الاوكرانيه او الاوروبيين اللي
بيدافعوا عن الحكومه الاوكرانيه وبين
الانفصاليين الروس
والمتطوعين
الروس الذين جاؤوا الى نجده بني جلدتهم في
شرق اوكرانيا
نفس القصه في ضم شبه جزيره القرم دخلت
جماعه فاجنر وغيرها من العسكريين بشكل غير
نظامي يعني او بدون يونيفورم ولعبوا دورا
في انجاز هذه المهمه دون ان يتدخل الجيش
الروسي اللي قال ما تم كله مساله داخليه
تماما لا شان به بها شبه جزيره القرم
ومواطنها يشتاقون الى ان ينضموا الى روسيا
الاتحاديه وطنهم التاريخي على العموم دي
قصه باتت مفهومه السبب الثاني هو انه هذه
الجماعات بتكون مدربه ومعدله للقيام بحرب
العصابات التي لا تبرع فيها القوات
النظاميه عاده وطبعا هذه الجامعات مستعده
للقيام باعمال قذره تخشى الجيوش ان تتورط
فيها الامر الثالث ان الاستعانه بهذه
الميليشيات بيخفف الضغوط الداخليه على
الشاشه لانه الخسائر التي تقع في هذه في
صفوف هذه الشركات او الجماعات المسلحه لا
تحسب على الخسائر الرسميه لجيوش هذه الدول
فالامريكان لما بيحسبوا خسائرهم الرسميه
في افغانستان او العراق او في اي دوله
الروس لما بيحسبوا خسائرهم في اوكرانيا لا
يقومون بحساب الالاف التي تسقط في صفوف
هذه الجماعات المرتزقه
رئيس جماعه اللي هو يفجيني المعلومات
المتواتره حوله من مصادر روسيه متعدده
بتشير بمنتهى البساطه الى انه رجل عاش
مراهقه اجراميه في السنوات الاخيره من عمر
الاتحاد السوفيتي انتهت بعشر سنوات في
السجن بعد ادانته في السطو المسلع على
سيده خرج مع سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي يعني
بدايه من ديسمبر 1991
وبدا مطعما صغيرا تحول في ظروف غامضه جدا
لسلسله مطاعم فاخره ساعدته في تكوين
علاقات مع النخب الروسيه التي كانت تاكل
في مطاعمه وبهذه الصفه او في هذا الاطار
تعرف على بوتين الذي استعان به لتنظيم
حفلات العشاء لكبار الضيوف الروس ولذلك
اشتهر بلقب طباخ بوتين لكن رجل الاعمال
الطموح انتقل ايضا في ظروف غامضه ليؤسس
جماعه فاجنر تحت اشراف
كويس وكبار القاده السياسيين على
تجاوزاتهم صمت القاده السياسيين فهم على
ان السبب انه يحظى بدعم من بوتين لكن صمت
بوتين بدات توضع عليه علامات استفهام
وبدات تظهر تفسيرات متعدده لسبب الصمت
الرسمي على تجاوزات وانتقادات
الغير مسبوقه ده رجل بيحصل على تمويله
وسلاحه وحياته كلها يعني مرهونه برضا
الدوله الروسيه لكنه ينتقد وزاره الدفاع
وكفاءتها والجيش وبشكك في جدول الحرب ليلا
ونهارا ظهرت مجموعه من التفسيرات التفسير
الاول ان انتقاداته جزء من خداع استراتيجي
للاوكران والغرب ليس لدي ذخيره انا في
حاله ضعف ثم تاتي الذخيره فاعتقدوا ان هذا
التكتيك لاستدراج الاوكران في الوقت الذي
يريد ان يستدرجهم فيه بدا هذا التفسير في
البدايه معقولا احيانا ثم بدا مت بل
ومستحيلا فيما بعد تفسير الثاني ان يلعب
دورا لصالح بوتين الذي يستعد الانتخابات
ويريد ان يبحث عن كبش فداء لتعثر العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا وليس هناك اسهل من
الاطاحه بالقاده العسكريين وتحميلهم فشل
الحرب بعيدا عنه وبالتالي استعانه لفتح
يعني جوانب التقصير في اداء القاده
العسكريين وطبعا تذكروا اصراره على انه
عقدته العسكريه احب وطني اطيعوا بوتين ولا
اهتم بشيء بدا هذا تفسيرا معقولا حتى
حواره يوم 24 مايو الذي تجاوز فيه لاول
مره انتقاد قاده الجيش الى التشكيك في
جدول الحرب والتطاول على النخب الروسيه
بشكل يؤجج مشاعر عامه الشعب وهو ما لا
يمكن ابدا ان يخدم بيتن في بوتين في اي
شيء
الاحتمال الثالث هو ان قبضه بوتين قد ضعفت
بالفعل وان هناك صراعا على السلطه في
موسكو وان يمهد لدورا سياسيا اكبر في
مرحله ما بعد بوتين بالتركيز على بطولاته
ودوره الوطني وانحيازه لجماهير الشعب
الفقير وعدم كفاءه القاده العسكريين وطبعا
بيركز على فشل مغامره بوتين في اوكرانيا
وبعد احداث 23 و 24 يونيو الماضي يعني
يبدو ان الاحتمال الثالث هو الفرديه
الصحيحه على الاقل حتى تتضح الامور امور
كثيره ليست واضحه وتحتاج الى تفسير وانا
بتابع الاحداث امبارح واول امبارح
والحقيقه قبلها شويه دايما بتذكر كلمه
العجيبه الغريبه اللي قال فيها ان روسيا
ليست الا لغز ملفوف في لغز محاطه بالالغاز
على العموم ده بياخذنا الى المحور الاخير
وهو التداعيات المحتمله
لمغامره طباخ بوتين انتهى التمرد وانتهت
المغامره لكن تداعياتها لم تنتهي كلام عن
عدم جدوى الحرب وفشلها لن يذهب سدد وسوف
يظل يعمق الاسئله حول مستقبل الحرب
ونتائجها ويعمق حاله التململ وعدم الرضا
بين فئات من الشعب الروسي لا تريد هذه
الحرب
ابعاد رئيس فاجنر
وتفقيق قيادات الشركه او ربما تفكيك فاجنر
كلها سوف يكون له تداعيات مؤقته على مسار
الحرب في اوكرانيا وسوف يكون له على
الارجح تداعيات على مصالح اوكرانيا على
مصالح روسيا الخارجيه لانه فاجنر كانت
ذراعا قويا لروسيا في العديد من الدول وما
حدث ربما يؤثر على عملياتها في مالي
ودوله افريقيا الوسطى والسودان وفي كثير
من دول العالم كلام كثير يمكن ان يقال عن
تداعيات مغامره
خصوصا بعد ان تتضح الصوره ويعرف ما جرى
وراء الكواليس لكن المؤكد ان اخطر هذه
التداعيات في تقديري هو اهتزاز صوره بوتين
واهتزاز صوره الدوله الروسيه كيف اهتزت
بوصول قوات متمرده الى القرب من العاصمه
على مسافه 200 كيلو مترا فقط وانه يحتاج
الرئيس الروسي الى وساطه رئيس دوله اخرى
للتوسط بين بوتين وبين رئيس جماعه متمرده
وان يخرج الرجل سالما الى بيلاروس بامان
هذا امر سوف يكون له تداعيات كثيره واحد
من هذه التداعيات انه قد يشجع طيارا
موجودا في واشنطن يؤمن ويدعو منذ فتره على
الاقل منذ بدايه الحرب لضروره اسقاط بوتين
بل والى تفكيك الدوله الروسيه ويعتقد ان
هذه المهمه دوبل يمكن انجازها باقل قدر
ممكن من الخسائر لان روسيا ليست الا بيتا
من ورق ما جرى يعطي مصداقيه لهذا التيار
والذي عنه سوف يكون لنا حلقه مقبله باذن
الله اشكركم والى اللقاء